it was definitely intriguing but but yes
i was also going well what what are we
going to do
yeah and i'm so glad that was a bit
mysterious right
these three together it's so weird to
see them all
about getting together with these people
and revisiting
you know what
what was part of my history and and
getting a chance to like come together
and
um there there are personal things too
which are
um
kind of resolutions or
um a way to revisit and and
um i'm not quite sure how to put it it's
just just to get to get back into that
and
i don't want to say like close the
chapter but revisit and have certain
resolutions
don't want to close the chat just join
in this like loving creative spirit
i hear what you're saying what about
andrew
fan service which you know it partially
is but like this is a movie that is
about a coming of age like an acceptance
of loss acceptance of death
taking responsibility for your gifts and
the
like i was taught
by the journal that tom went on and that
he was having to it was just
a werewolf
with with his girlfriend's best friend
and sacrificed that in order it's just
it's the it's classic peter parker but
it felt totally fresh and totally
reimagined like
his origin like tom's origin story was
happening in his third movie rather than
his first like there's something so
profound so the film still stands alone
without very interesting
showing up very interesting i i agree so
if this is his origin where do we go
from here welcome back to new rock stars
toby mcguire's uncanny return and
spider-man no way home as our friendly
neighborhood youth pastor might not be
the last time we see him as an interview
with all three peter parkers with
deadline confirms that this guy
deliberately is not closing the chapter
on his version of the character we'll
try something new here maguire
i don't know if it works
i'm still deciding how i feel about it
jury's still out but this is inside
marvel new rockstars weekly marvel
reaction show i'm eric voss with me is
mt
eric mcguire did he say that like the
guy that gets me really interested as to
like he's not closing the chapter like
are we gonna see more toby mcguire eric
or just
obviously toby mcguire isn't running
this studio but it seems like he's
afraid to step up
right
i don't know what that guy that guy's
been in the industry for a long time
right he's he's been at a lot of poker
tables who knows
who owes him
imagine like kevin feige takes off a
basket it's toby maguire it's like it's
me the whole time
everyone is toby with the club
well uh this whole interview with tom
holland toby maguire andrew garfield was
just so fascinating to watch it
constantly keeps you guessing how these
boys truly rank as peter 1 peter 2 peter
3.
we're gonna decode what toby might have
meant by that as well as what andrew
garfield meant by suggesting no way home
was actually the origin story for tom
holland's peter parker and where that
version of peter could and should go
from here but before we get in all that
we are less than two weeks away from new
rockstars live show in chicago friday
february 11th 8pm at talia hall it's
gonna be me and jess clements tommy beck
told philip molina mixing it up with
some fun surprises that we have never
done here on the channel before i don't
want to tell you yet it's a special
surprise just for the people who come to
our chicago live show now this event is
hosted by your partners at rooster teeth
part of their very normal podcast tour
and we are sharing the night with
hilarious guys at the face jam podcast
so tickets are still available check out
the link in the description and if you
live in the chicago area i would love to
meet you in person because people i
realize are so nice
they're so wonderful when you just meet
them uh it's on twitter i don't really
get a sense of you
i don't know whether you got a knife in
your hand when you're treated
when i see you in person i realize we're
all just people just merging out over
the same stuff
and i want to nerd out together with you
now that it's stealing yo take that
knife combat out you do not want to put
any knife ideas in people's hands and
you're about to meet them from
well it's hard to tweet and write an and
how old knife at the same time like
some we have some foodies some home
chefs who like to tweet but you know you
don't have to do two things at the same
time right
uh anyway
we are already off the rails once again
let's do that
i love it what's your question this week
well obviously the most important
question of this week is is toby
returning after the events of spiderman
no way home yes uh now it's fun to think
uh two years ago right before everything
went to hell
everything was going great uh we had no
idea what was before us um uh birds of
prey was about to come out in the movie
theaters uh sonic was on the horizon
uh onward pixar's onward was gonna break
box office records uh but
the thing that i was most excited for at
that time was uh sam raimi was hired to
take over directing for doctor strange
the multiverse of madness now it was uh
mixed feelings for me because i love
scott derrickson i was bummed to see him
part ways with that and i will watch
anything scott derrickson makes uh
beyond this but sam raimi right like
this uh for me was when the toby and
andrew garfield speculation train left
the station officially because even
though dr strange's sequel was a
completely different movie the fact that
sam raimi was being brought back into
this universe just made it feel more
possible that marvel studios still had a
reverence for that past era rather than
just forgetting it ever happened they
might have similar conversations with
the actors and we now know that was
totally the case there was truth to
those suspicions because andrew garfield
confirmed last week on ellen that he
knew he would be coming back as
spider-man for two years before the
movie came out meaning those talks with
andrew and toby were happening around
the same time december 2019 january 2020
right around the time kevin feige was
approaching sam raimi for multiverse of
madness the respect for raymie
throughout this whole process can even
be seen in a screenplay for no way home
in which chris mckinnon and eric summers
identified toby's character as the raimi
vs peter not just for simplicity they
could have put the actor's name there
they put actors names all over the
script in this case they wanted to
credit those directors now before sony
rebooted the spider-man franchise with
mark webb and andrew garfield sam raimi
was set to direct the fourth toby film
toby remained on great terms with raymie
was ready to come back but only if
rainey directed it so now as we look
ahead to multiverse of madness we cannot
help but wonder does that rainy
connection mean that marvel studios
wanted to really set up a toby and raimi
your reunion and multiverse of madness
is this why toby was reluctant to say
no way home was the closing chapter of
his character i just want to quickly
break down what resolutions he mentioned
some resolutions in the interviews so
what resolutions did his character go
through in the no way home events he
told andrew garfield peter parker that
he had he and mj had eventually figured
things out which is important to note at
the end of spider-man 3 in 2007
it wasn't completely all things happy
ending there they
hadn't even firmly said i love you they
hadn't kissed they were set to get
engaged here they're just kind of slow
dancing and crying that didn't mean so
much
i really love that um but here they they
were able to figure it out um he also
emotionally recalled harry osborne
trying to kill him later dying in his
arms one of my favorites
um piping fluid in a test tube not a
good time to get emotional
but i think it was important why he was
in that headspace what was he doing in
the moment he was brewing up that
anti-serum to fix norman osborn
something that he said
he had been thinking about for years of
his life telling us that he viewed all
of that as the watershed nexus moment
that he wished he could rewind to any
race not that you know he doesn't have a
problem of him getting bitten as
spider-man it's the fact that norman
osborne uh
had that live accident that really
screwed up his life that much because it
led to him losing his friend uh led to
all of his problems i think that death
uh the don't tell harry kunk
has been like seared into his uh uh
unconscious and it's been haunting him
um
and then he told doc och interestingly
they had that little moment of he's like
i'm trying to do better oh my god such a
satisfying recall
i love that uh and then he helped tom
holland peter learn to let go of his
anger agrees against green goblin and in
doing so he took a stab to the kidney
but he survived and he said the last
thing he said i think before fading back
into his reality was just kind of an
acknowledgement that he's still in a lot
of pain which is an interesting way to
leave that character you know like uh
what what types of pain you know as boba
fett uh wisely tells us the inner scars
take longer to heal
so
i want to ask you mt do we want to see
toby maguire cameo in multiverse of
madness might that overshadow big cameos
in that movie um and then in the plot
for this character's fictional future
what future remains in store for him
hmm well i definitely feel like a toby
maguire cameo
i don't think it's necessary but as long
as it serves the story as long as it
stirs like the overall tale that our
reimi wants to tell but
with the introduction of the multiverse
or the formal the more formal
introduction of the multiverse with um
no way home it would be wise to sort of
just like tease like all right here's
where the boys went here's where andrew
and toby went after the no way home and
like we sort of just get a tease of like
all right here's what the universes are
we don't have to go deep into
um like including toby into the story of
multiverse of madness unless again it
serves the overall of dr strange's tale
and he's going to serve the team that
he's building up in in a way that you
know in a good way so i i think it'd be
dope but like you know i just don't want
it to be like a get like not or gimmicky
or like all right come on to buy some
tickets the multiverse badges because we
got toby here you like spider-man um so
yeah but not just fan service yeah as
long as it's not just friend servers
exactly um and but in terms of the
future um for this character there's
obviously very much a future they very
much set up a future for both toby and
andrew um i definitely feel like having
raymie um working with marvel studios
with multiples of badness um and getting
to hear his ideas um for spider-man 4 i
feel like marvel studios and sony will
be able to you know sort of take those
ideas
and you know craft them into a new
narrative for toby in the future because
i definitely don't i definitely feel
like sony is not letting toby go toby
they're not like toby or andrew go
they're probably gonna start their own
like give them both sequels at some
point because they're they would make
millions of dollars billions of dollars
uh if a spider-man 4 came out so i
definitely feel like we're not done with
tobey maguire as spider-man for sure
yeah i think the the real question would
be for future sony films right because
see that version of spider-man all
versions of spider-man are still sony
properties in terms of the film
distribution rights in the film
exhibition all that stuff like if he
wants to be featured on screen in a tv
show a streaming series a movie whatever
sony has to okay it so uh the only way
that uh a toby or any of these weird
cameos make sense in any of these movies
is if they as you said do something to
advance the plot if they help the
character in their present crisis that
was the case in an end game which i
would say those weren't even cameos
because they were all just like marvel
mcu characters just fighting for the
fate of reality at that point but uh and
spider-man no way home you hear in this
interview
one thing that andrew and toby keep
coming back to is that their cameos are
necessary for tom hall and peter
parker's journey
into maturity into accepting loss they
help him not just physically in that
battle and saving his life but they save
his soul uh they have a necessary role
it's not just like to use another
example
um x-men apocalypse right one of the
best parts of that movie was when
hugh jackman showed up as wolverine at
the lab when the younger versions of
jean grey and scott summers are in there
but he serves no necessary role in the
movie they just wouldn't have
[Laughter]
it's oh to have you jackman here right
so let's bring them in
and i think it speaks to just how much
of a team player hugh jackman is oh my
god
i'll show up in this movie uh and it
speaks to the fans the fact that that
was like her favorite part of the movie
but in terms of like the movie as a
whole it didn't really do anything to
move the ball forward uh and i would
even say this is a hot take hot take
okay civil war civil war one of my
favorite scenes in that movie one of my
favorite scenes in the mcu is the
introduction of peter parker in queens
queens flash oh my god
brother never forget it that was one of
the biggest cheers just the word
i cheered i was excited i always cheer
when i see a queen eric i always cheat
for my queen that's right
[Laughter]
but like they have uh yeah just like the
camera following the back of his head
with his with his ear with zero buds in
as he's going into his apartment we need
him having him talk to tony stark so
great
that did not serve the plot of civil war
at all and in fact i think it hurt the
film overall to have that in the movie
it made the mcu a much better place i
don't want to rewind history and erase
that from the movie and sometimes you
see this throughout the mcu films the
movies the the two to three act movie
that they have always three acts but
like two hours it starts to
lose some of its steam because they
forcing these cameos in there and it
just distracts us from the core conflict
of that movie and i think i i've griped
about this before and it is just a
pedigree because overall i really do
love civil war uh but it does
uh make it a bit problematic for tony
stark to be a character who is solely
motivated to begin this movie by the
death of a kid through the avengers
actions
right and he feels so much guilt that he
says we have to sign the sakovia accords
and then what does he do as soon as
things start to turn south he's like i
got back up a child
in queens you know what i never actually
thought about that
a super powered child a child who can
like you know tilt buses and lift cars
sure absolutely but a child nonetheless
and he puts a child in the most
dangerous battle tony stark has ever
faced in his career in another country
and he flies him there he gets his
head of security to fly him there and it
just like it makes us a little confused
what tony stark is in this for now a lot
of people said well both cap and tony
start to make bad decisions in this
movie i agree but i don't think the
movie itself does a good enough job
throwing guilt on both of these men for
making their stupid choices i think if
anything it tries to justify their
decisions
by saying oh well
captain america wouldn't you do anything
in the world to protect your friend oh
tony stark wouldn't you do anything and
to avenge your mother and father's death
uh i honestly think these two guys with
all their history would just at least
talk before taking swings at each other
and you could say they did talk they had
that whole thing about the pens it was
enough think about them they would not
would not
try to kill each other
uh anyway but hey the places we got was
awesome rad yes
other than that noka plates i and of
course i'm going to have people tweeted
me saying you didn't understand civil
war yes i've only watched civil war 12
times millions of times
i have watched this movie so many times
analyzing it making a meal out of it and
i can i can love civil war i can love
that spider-man scene in civil war but i
can also argue that spider-man scene did
start to muddy the overall themes of
that story and and uh take our attention
away so why am i bringing all this up
into spider-man
if toby mcguire ever shows up again as a
cameo or any uh surprising cameo shows
up in a story they need to forward the
central conflict and the central
character arc in a meaningful way not
just the plot not just a logical plot
they help them fight a battle it needs
to matter to the soul of the character
that character needs to honestly it
helps if that character's reluctant to
that person coming in their world like i
was fine before you got here i didn't
need your advice which is what i thought
no way home did so well uh tom holland
uh peter parker thought he knew better
than these guys and until they literally
finished his sentence
then
only then was he on board with them so
to your point nt i've been talking for a
long time i um
i think uh with if toby oguard were to
ever return i think the only way it
would make sense in a movie like uh
you know avengers secret wars or sooner
and multiverse of madness uh would be if
that marvel title is a true well we got
everyone like we got every x-men
character from the past franchises like
if if his uh presence would be missed
it's like well you couldn't also get
them you know like i think that's the
only way and it would have to be quick
it would have to just be like a really
quick like deadpool to uh like they're
in the background and in that case like
i know what i'm saying well that was
just a random cameo how did that serve
the plot and that case it really is just
like a joke cameo it's an alfred
hitchcock walk through the background i
think it would have to be all these
people are really fast and don't
necessarily serve the objectives of dr
strange or wanda maximoff uh they are
more incidental of their decisions uh as
opposed to uh
like effects uh or uh causal causes of
their decisions if that makes sense
um they are a set dressing in a way yeah
for sure i feel like um the best way to
include toby maguire in multiverse of
madness but still have him serve the
story in a way is if we just introduce
uh madame webb and like the whole you
know spider-verse thing i like the
spider-verse concept in multiverse of
madness and have toby maguire sort of
just be like the the sort of
introduction to all of that to come and
like you know just like just sort of
just like all right this is an element
of the multiverse here's madame webb
and like there's toby and like that's it
you know like you don't have to make it
again like as long as toby would set
like serve the story then include him
but like if he's not really going to be
a huge thing then like you know just
just mention uh madame webb and then
like i don't know maybe show a flash of
toby a little bit like that's it um you
don't have to like you know force him in
if he doesn't fit anyway right i agree
with you i think madame webb absolutely
need to be like miles morales needed to
be introduced yesterday
um but we talked about what's the best
role for toby going forward like they
called him this cool youth pastor right
he was this great mentor not just to
peter parker but to ned every young
person who had a conversation with them
walked away from that greeting
changed with a new outlook and believing
in spider jesus
thanks you're fasting
i guess what i'm saying is like
if we talk about what role he could play
to the live-action cinematic universe
there's a lot of talk about miles
morales being brought in right and he
that he would need a mentor that he had
uh like in the animated into the
spider-verse do we think tom holland's
version of the character is as good of a
mentor figure as toby's take on the
character might be imagine this scenario
we're talking about another spider-man
another tobey maguire spider-man movie
they have this live-action spider-verse
they can just keep making sequels for
all of these different guys we have
another tube mcguire one but in that
universe is where we introduce the miles
morales i kind of see a reality where
where either toby or maybe andrew are
more of that mentor to miles morales uh
and then tom holland can keep doing his
own thing i just still see tom holland
is still like this young guy going
through his own thing
just through the first act of his origin
story i don't need to see him now being
a teacher i don't want that guy teaching
anybody he still has lessons to learn
yeah maybe in a couple more movies he
can be the teacher but like now we want
to see him in the adult phase i'm like
all right here's me learning how to be
an adult because i don't think if you
are going to introduce miles morales as
a as a student to some other spider-man
which i would argue you don't
necessarily need that i think miles
morales can like these guys learn his
lessons on his own but i'm just saying
if they are going through that plan of
it introduce him in andrew's world or in
toby's world and then use you know
through some crazy multiversal stuff
avengers secret wars or whatever it is
bring miles into the mcu uh i know there
already is a miles in the mcu through
donald glover's line and homecoming
there was this line in no way home where
andrew goes yeah there probably is
another spider-man out there yeah black
spider-man out there yes he does exist
out there uh i just think toby might be
a really really fun option to consider
as a mentor figure to him in a way that
still lets miles morales gets all the
cool action in that movie that'd be a
great element to include in a potential
spider-man 4 scenario with tobey maguire
it's like all right here's miles morales
and like i'm you know i'm old and like i
just kind of want to just be with mary
jane so here you go you're glad
take the spider
legacy go on but we will see what comes
next from him we actually have some
thoughts on andrew garfield's
interesting statements in this deadline
interview but first we want to thank
some friends who helped us make this
episode thanks to upstart for sponsoring
this episode if you dread looking at
your credit card statements you are not
alone the weight of debt can be
crippling but upstart can help you on
your path to financial freedom upstart
is a fast and easy way to pay off your
debt with a personal loan all online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over a million
people have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date rather than looking at
credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income your
current employment your credit history
define you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate without
impacting your credit score in minutes
for loans between one thousand and fifty
thousand dollars you can even receive
funds as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com marvel that's
upstart.com marvel don't forget to use
our url to let them know that we sent
you loan amounts we determined based on
your credit income certain other
information provided in your loan
application upstart.com marvel we also
want to thank brooke lennon for
sponsoring this episode whether you just
realize your best friend and girlfriend
don't remember anything about you you
are just having a regular or if you're
just having a regular monday it's nice
to be cozy and comfortable brooke lennon
is here to ensure your coziness
threshold is reached with their line of
abetting and home essentials brooklyn
was founded to create luxury home
essentials at prices that didn't break
the bank they worked directly with
manufacturers to give you great products
at a fair price no middlemen no markups
brooklyn makes betting for every kind of
sleeper and they have so much more than
just the internet's favorite sheets
they've got plush pillows absorbent
towels cozy fleece loungewear and more
shopping doesn't get any easier than
brooklyn and bundles save more when you
stock up on essentials for your space
there's a reason brook london has over
one hundred thousand five star reviews
and counting go to brooklyn.com and use
promo code marvel to get 20 off your
purchase of 100 or more that's b r o o k
l i n e n dot com and use promo code
marvel for 20 off refresh your wrist
with the comfort essentials brook linen
and we want to thank helix for
sponsoring this episode because speaking
of good sleep the last thing you want is
to be tossing and turning because you're
on a bum mattress that's why you've got
to get yourself a helix mattress helix
sleep has a sleep quiz that matches your
body type and your sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you they have
soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot even a helix plus mattress
for plus size sleepers i have a helix
mattress i love it the quiz match made
with a medium firm mattress with lumbar
support it sleeps cool the mattress
ships right to your door for free no
need to go to a mattress store just go
to helix sleep.com inside marvel take
their two minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
light they have a 10 year warranty and
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
marvel all right nt let's get back to
this deadline interview right what's
going on with what andrew garfield said
yeah eric so was no way home tom hall
and peter parker's origin story and if
so what is next for the young boy what
is going what's gonna happen to him
yeah i think that's a fascinating way to
describe what we saw tom holland go
through in no way home because he's
totally right like the fact that like to
hear the words with great power must
also come great responsibility that is
kind of the moment spider-man despite
everything this kid has gone through
over three more movies with end game
infinity war civil war uh that is really
the moment it all comes together for him
which suggests that we need to see more
from him
and i think like the fact that he is now
going through uh he's listening to
police scanners right he's stitched his
own costume together he is uh studying
for the ged he's living by himself in
the city no one knows who he is
i think there is a great opportunity uh
again we were talking before
about whether this character tom
holland's take on peter needs to be
immediately the mentor to miles morales
we need to see miles morales in this
cinematic universe i don't know if this
version of peter parker is the one to
bring him in i think the two should be
friends at some point i think they
should meet i think they should fight on
battles you know they should have a
rivalry there's all kinds of great stuff
that can be told i don't think peter
needs to be his mentor i think there's a
great opportunity to see peter as just
like a struggling uh freelancer working
in the city trying to solve crimes but
he's hunted you know and the fact that
he's alone makes an interesting
interesting place to potentially bring
in craven the hunter as a villain oh my
god that would be right but no but
wanted to bring in craven craven was
their backup option if they couldn't get
all these multiples multiversal cameos
for no way home they were going to do a
craven story now is the time for our
craven story like
just seeing this version of peter parker
have to deal with like he can't he can't
uh rely on uh the companionship of his
loved ones he's now just targeted by
another loner and just have these two
go after each other i think that this is
the next story i want to see from him i
would love to see both craven and
scorpion um sort of just like i don't
know maybe not working together but like
sort of both going after peter at the
same time and just like michael coming
back after oh my god michael armando is
such a good actor like if you ever
played far cry 3 that man is like one of
the best video game villains of all time
so like i'm so excited to see him as
scorpion the craven would be an
excellent way to like further that
spider-man story uh but i also think
that uh black cat
is for sure going to be introduced
because we have um mj not
not remembering peter and peter feeling
alone and being on the run so like black
cat i feel like is the perfect like
person to
like be like hey peter you're a criminal
do crime with me let's just do crime um
but yeah i i feel like it's either
craven or or or black cat i feel like
that'd be a good or is it venom right is
it venom is this the next story with
them the way we get that little piece of
the venom symbiote left in the mcu is
this the one that comes after him is
that what's next for him uh where he has
to deal with some other incarnation of
venom and because i'm trying to imagine
if you're kevin feige if you're the
other execs at marvel you are trying to
pitch sony a story that says this
version of peter parker this next story
has to be interconnected with the mcu so
what are they getting out of it they are
going to want venom somehow connected to
the mcu i think they love the idea of
that venom peace staying in their
universe because for sure the mind races
with all kinds of uh hosts that this
symbiote can bond with and attach to and
make another venom version of it not
just the regular humans of his world but
any of the superheroes we've seen as
guardians ravagers
of
super soldiers uh all kinds of dangerous
people who are out there who uh the
venom symbiote would be terrified i
would love if the symbiote was like for
a little while anyway the new stan lee
just keeps popping up in movies just
like the little like
the little like splotch of like i'm
coming am i going for bucky
[Music]
just never actually
bonds with anything sort of like
goldilocks he just takes a taste he's
like
just leaves so uh putting ourselves back
in marvel studios position right so like
spider-man homecoming promised the
team-up of spider-man with tony stark
with iron man right and everything that
that means in terms of what kind of tech
uh peter parker would now have what kind
of responsibility peter parker would now
have what kind of humor in in in
a character interaction and the people
of tony stark's orbit like happy hogan
like pepper potts right and then
spider-man far from home brought in nick
fury and then other ex-shield operatives
skrulls you know uh people from that
part of the mcu and then now in
spider-man no way home it's doctor
strange and the other sorcerers wong
those apprentices who are shoveling snow
and then ned we now learn also a
sorcerer so who else in the mcu do we
need to see peter parker who's still
around i mean we had his little moment
with captain marvel an endgame we had
his little moment with hulk in infinity
war that i really loved i kind of want
to see peter parker team up with ruffalo
i want to see it oh my god that's the
natural next step because like he's a
nerd and he really wants a mentor like
to some degree so like bro they would
nerd out so hard i want to see that so
much because like you should just love
his biology but like what are you made
of like we're both kind of science
freaks let's just smoke each other's
blood
well and that's my thinking i had my
theory explanation of how i think this
version of peter parker got his powers
and i i really do think that this peter
parker sometimes after the avengers left
avengers tower in 2015 to move upstate
there was still some like
in that tower and this version of
peter parker snooped around there and
classically in the comics it was a gamma
irradiated spider right
that's so if we imagine that bruce
banner's powers came from gamma
radiation this could be a natural link
to where we finally found out what peter
parker's origin story is is that he was
wandering around bruce banner's gamma
lab in avengers tower got bitten by a
gamma radiant spider and these two might
have that common link that kind of
common nerdy engineering approach they
both got exposed to too much gamma
radiation one person directly while
experimenting with a super soldier serum
blood uh and then the other one through
a spider bite and that could just be a
really fun goofy but uh beautiful story
of true nerds and peter doesn't have to
act like he's the smartest one in the
room and doesn't have to worry about
that impostor syndrome uh and that these
two uh you know meek nerds
kids their powers together
i love that term meek nerds you gotta
love a meek nerd i i do love that
connection between uh peter's powers and
gamma radiation and like that got me
thinking what if
the leader is somehow involved in
the development of peter parker's
biology um because that'd be because we
haven't seen him since the incredible
hulk with edward norton he like he coach
sort of got that blood
dropping on his head and he's he was
very much obsessed with gamma radiation
in in in the effects of the human blood
having him his involvement within the
the actual origins of spider-man would
be a great mcu thing to do i would love
that tim blake nelson yeah he's
everywhere him showing up in watchmen um
he was just so great i want to see that
guy born he is still somewhere alive in
the mcu
yeah
empty one of my favorite things about
you is your ability to bring back things
from like
mcu movies that are technically canon
but no one really cares right
but you're not wrong these are now part
of the world and tim lake nelson's an
incredible actor bring him back bring
him back let's do it i think we weren't
supposed to be the mole man um in the
a fantastic four i could be mistaken but
i know he's in that movie
uh but i could be wrong i don't know
and if multiverse of madness makes canon
all past fantastic four in past x-men
movies
there's gonna be all kinds of weird
anomalies i mean we're speaking of
anomalies we're talking about craven
earlier it's it would just be pretty
weird to see aaron taylor johnson back
in the mcu but as a different character
not the first time this has happened
right actors have come back jimmy chan
played two different characters michelle
yellow just played two different
characters but this would be a pretty
high high profile one a character we saw
memorably die on screen but i think this
comes back to
you know this question of canonicity
we're thinking about it a lot right with
like
with uh potentially
agents of shield maybe hopefully
being confirmed as canon i hope so uh
the netflix stories now coming over is
canon the uh and then over on the dc
side of things all the questions with
like what zack snyder has worked on
versus what joss whedon did to justice
league versus
you know uh with the new flash movie
what is considered canon you know in a
multiverse is it just canon even matter
anymore and ultimately i think what
we're learning is whether or not
something is canon is really just based
on the mind of whoever is at the wheel
of the franchise
and the fact now that if you look at her
at star wars dave filoni's at the wheel
this guy just by including certain lines
of dialogue in the book of boba fett and
the mandalorian in bad batch is now a
firmly establishing things as canon that
around 2015 we weren't so sure about
anymore right you know when the force
awakens came out and then like disney
overtook the star wars franchise we were
worried that
maybe some of the things we loved most
about legends would just be erased from
truth in the history it would just be
some kind of fan fiction now right but
now dave palone is saying no i'm at the
wheel and thrawn is real thrawn happened
you know he brought him back in rebels
and now he's gonna be a live action
so i think that gives us hope you know
uh but it also just reminds us that like
whatever logic you may have for why
something wasn't erased it only matters
how insofar as how excited the executive
producer in charge of the the creative
vision of these stories
considers it to be important and wants
to remember it and things like avengers
age of ultron and some of the earlier
phase one stuff of marvel whatever
happened there
you could imagine kevin feige now saying
like we're still figuring stuff out
and we don't really partner with that
one particular filmmaker anymore so some
of the weird stuff they did in that
movie we're not really going to pretend
actually happened
so i
i'm not saying that quicksilver's still
alive but in terms of how sacred they're
gonna be about who plays quicksilver in
the mcu going forward i don't think
they're going to treat quicksilver's
death in age of ultron as something
that uh permanent or anyone's death that
permanent now i know i'm probably
contradicting other things i've said
when it came to one division how you
know wanda was still clearly affected by
her brother's death from the battle of
sokovia i understand that i'm probably
just speaking out my ass at this point
we're late in the episode i understand
but
uh when it comes to uh characters who
come back whoever is going to be
affecting uh uh or battling or joining
tom holland peter parker in his next
movie uh i don't think they're going to
be as sacred or bound by the rules
that we previously thought we were bound
by and i think if anything proved that
it was spider-man no way home and the
fact that in this movie we had
multiversal via magic crossovers from
other realities
while also having jk simmons play j
jonah jameson and none of us cared no it
doesn't make total sense but we still
love it we just wanted to see him we
just love jk simmons man
so the multiverse logic just kind of
makes everything possible and it's okay
and that's out for anything just throw
this i just want to see the people that
i used to see again like jk simmons yeah
toby mcguire just bring them in as long
as it serves a store well that is it for
this ridiculous episode of inside marvel
uh again february 11th 8pm tally hall in
chicago if you're in the chicago area
this is going to be like
it's our first time being able to
connect with people in the real world
i'm so excited for it you aren't going
to want to miss this come say hello come
talk soon hi
we're eager to say hello uh also don't
forget to check out our many great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com
i don't want to promise anything but
i'll tell you if you come to chicago
there might be something for you
uh wait i don't know
i might give away some of my shirts some
of my shirts i don't know if the company
i don't know if that epic carol can do
this he's talking to the shirt she's
back
i'm not always able to wear i don't mind
handing them out to you right right hey
so that's not an incentive i don't know
what will well follow me at eavos follow
mt mastertainment subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
thank you so much for watching we'll see
you next week
you